foreign
president of the Russian Federation
Vladimir
Putin
good afternoon
a dear members of stay Duma senators
dear citizens of Russian Federation
in today's address
I am
I I I'm giving this state address in a
very difficult uh context in a very
difficult time
there are cardinal major changes in uh
in the world there are historic changes
that determine the future of our country
and our people
every one of us has
a great responsibility
about a year ago in order to protect our
people on our historic land in order to
ensure Security in order to liquidate
the threat that appeared from the give
regime after the military coup in 2014
we decided to conduct a special military
operation
step by step
we will continue to resolve the
objectives that are before us starting
from 2014 donbass has been fighting
um to defend its right to live on its
territory and speak its own language
they were fighting and not giving up in
conditions of a blockade and constant
shelling and in the context of
complete hatred from the key of regime
they waited and they believed that the
Russia would come to their help
you know this very well that we did
everything possible indeed everything
possible in order to resolve this
problem in a peaceful way
we were patient in our negotiations
to come out of this horrible conflict
however behind our backs a completely
different scenario was being prepared
the
assurances from the Western leaders to
ensure peace in donbass turned out to be
a lie they were just dragging time and
they were trying to close their eyes to
the political killings and repressions
of the key of regime and
abuse of uh
religion and terrorist acts in donbass
in Western academies and training
centers they were training nationalist
units and supplying weapons I would like
to emphasize that it was before the
special military
operation they were negotiating the
supply of heavy military equipment and
planes and
anti-aircraft defense systems and they
were also publicly talking about supply
of nuclear weapons
NATO and Western countries were setting
their military bases on our borders and
biological Laboratories and they were
training
on the future theater of military
actions
and
today they recognized this they publicly
recognized this without shying away
they
they uh
talking about Minsk agreements and nor
among dormant agreement to be just a
show a spectacle
and
when Russia I would like to emphasize
when Russia sincerely tried to find a
peaceful solution they were playing with
lives of people
and they were
playing a dirty game
and this
repulsive lie
and their behavior two-faced Behavior
was seen in Yugoslavia in Iraq Syria
and they will not be able to
wash away that shame ever
of uh centuries of colonialism and
dictatorship they used to this idea that
they could do anything that
they
it turns out that they are treating
their own people in this way they also
deceive their own people by telling them
stories about uh peaceful agreements in
donbass
and
it's just total and unprincipled lies
we have been insisting on protecting our
own interests and also that
protecting the position that there
should not be a situation in the world
where there are civilized countries in
the rest of the world
we were very open
and we were sincerely open for a
dialogue with the west and we were
insisting on
Europe and the rest of the world to have
uh an equal system of defense and equal
system of security we were proposing to
our partners this idea and in response
we were getting dishonest answers
but there were also specific actions
expansion of NATO to our borders
creation of new anti-rocket defense
systems in Europe
and developing military
contingents on the borders of Russia and
I'd like to emphasize that no other
country in the world has has many
foreign military bases as the United
States they have hundreds hundreds of
military bases around the world the
whole uh planet is dotted with their
bases
and
we saw them exit fundamental agreements
on limiting Rockets of medium to long
range
and they were exiting other agreements
supporting peace in the world
they were doing it for a reason
and in December 2021 we officially
directed to the US and to Europe
our request for guarantees for security
however we received a direct refusal
to our offers and it became clear that
the reaction
was demonstrated and the threat was
growing
and we had no doubt that by February
2022 everything was prepared for a
punitive action in donbass
where
key of regime
provided artillery and Aviation and
other weapons to to attack dambas back
in 2014.
in 2015 they
attempted again directly to directly
attack donbass they continued trailing
Terror in relation to Citizens all of
this was completely against
the documents that were accepted by the
United Nations security Council
I would like to
repeat they started the war
and we used the force in order to stop
it
those who planned a new attack on
danielsco and danbas on logansk they
clearly understood that the next
objective is strike against sevastopolin
Crimea we understood this and
they are again in key of talking
directly
about their plans and we knew that
already
we protect people and protect their
homes and the objectives of the West
is infinite power they spend 150 billion
dollars to support militarily give
regime to compare this to put this into
perspective in 2021 2022 the big seven
countries provided
to the poorest countries only 60 billion
Aid
also they and in exchange for that 60
billion they require
complete submission to their will
with this the flow of money to
finance the war is not stopping and they
continue supplying means to provide
coups in other countries
and at their recent security conference
there was an endless flow of accusations
against Russia and this was done it
seems in order for everyone to forget
that over the last 10 years it was the
West who opened uh who released the
genie from the bottle
as a result of wars
we did not come up with these figures
these figures are provided by them as a
result of wars
that were
started by United States since
2021 about 900 000 people died and
millions became refugees
and they're trying to delete this from
the memory of people they're trying to
pretend this did not happen but nobody
forgot that
the
people's tragedy is not important to
them
and they are betting trillions trillions
of dollars and they are trying to
continue robbing everyone else and
they're covering themselves with words
of democracy and values
they are trying to label uh other
countries and publicly insult them and
they are creating that image of enemy
within their own countries in order to
divert attention from corruption
scandals within their own countries
they are diverting attention from the
growing social economic problems I would
like to remind you that in 1930s Western
countries opened the path for Nazi
Germany to develop and in this Century
they
they did this to Ukraine and anyone who
knows history
and knows that this goes back to the
19th century Austrian Hungarian Empire
and
this was they only had the only a single
goal to separate these territories from
their historic ties with our country
there's nothing new everything is
repeating history keeps repeating
they have supported the coup in 2014 and
this was a bloody cool anti-state
anti-constitution cool and as if nothing
had happened and they even told us how
much money they spent on it
the ideological uh basis for this was
russophobia
and they were
it's a shame to to even say that one of
the units of the Ukrainian Army was
given a name Elvis it always is a is a
name of
of uh German Nazi uh German unit and
they have
they have a very popular Chevrons on
their uniform
uh with the German Nazi insignia
and they've got very much
signs on their tanks and their the new
neo-nazis are not even hiding uh who
they inherited their history from
and we see that those in power choose to
close their eyes on this why because
they don't give a damn
because they they are trying to fight us
they're trying to fight Russia
and that means they want to use anything
they want to use everyone terrorists
Nazis
even Devil Himself
to use it as weapon against Russia
the project anti-russia is a
reveranchist
policy against our country
in the back in the 30s of last century
and today it's the same idea to direct
aggression to the east to start the war
in Europe using other people's tools
[Music]
and we
we said that we're not fighting in
Ukraine we said that the Ukrainian
people have become a hostages of their
Western Masters who occupied this
country in in political in economic and
Military sense
of uh decades they were destroying
Ukrainian industry and robbing the
country and as a consequence of this it
became the
poverty and social division grew
and this was the material for the
military actions and of course
they turned these people into Canon
folder and this is a sad reality but
it's a fact the responsibility for
starting the conflict for growing number
of victims lies totally with the west
and with key of regime for whom
Ukrainian people are not their own
effectively
this regime is not serving their
national interests they're serving
interests of foreign powers
the
Ukraine is is now like a training ground
for them
I'm not going to talk about the plans of
Western powers to increase military aid
everyone knows about this but one thing
is is uh very clear to everyone the the
greater the range of this systems the
further away we will be forced to move
the threat from our borders
the elites of the West are not hiding
their goals
they are as they say trying to inflict a
strategic
um defeat on Russia what does that mean
to us that means they want to end with
Russia they want to turn a local
conflict into a phase of uh global
conflict
this is how we understand this and this
and we will react in an appropriate way
because in this case we're talking about
existence of our country
they also have to take into account that
it is impossible to defeat Russia on the
battlefield
so they increase their information
attacks and of course
they are targeting our Young Generation
and of course they'll they keep lying
here they're twisting historic facts
they're not uh
they're not they are going against our
culture against against our
religious organizations look at what
they've done to their own people they're
destroying family national identity
they are
abusing their children uh you know even
pedophili is is announced as a normal
thing in the West
and they uh they're recognizing same-sex
marriages that's fine that you they're
they're adults they've got the right to
live their life and we always were very
tolerant about this in Russia nobody is
trying to enter private lives of people
and we're not going to do this
however we need to tell them but look at
the scriptures
of any uh religion in the world
everything is said in there
and one of the things is that the family
is a union of a man and a woman
but even this sacred texts
are subjected to doubt
an Anglican Church
is planning to consider the idea of a
gender-neutral god what can you say here
millions of people in the west
understand that they are being led to uh
spiritual destruction
Elites are going crazy
and this cannot be cure it seems
but our duty is to protect our children
and we will do this we will protect our
children from degradation
it's obvious that the West will continue
trying to destabilize our society
they
they'll be using our traitors who've
been throughout the ages have the same
attitude to their own people hatred for
their own nation and this was the the
case forever
they are uh uh attempting terrorist
attacks that are that uh aimed at
destabilizing our society but we will
never be similar to Western uh regimes
and uh to Kiev regime
um who used who are used to witch
hunting we're not going to hunt those
who betrayed the motherland let them
live with this they have to live with it
what's important is that citizens of
Russia have to give them a moral
evaluation
we need to be proud that we are
a multicultural Nation
and majority of our people have a
principal position in relation to the
special military operation they
understand the meaning of it they
supported our actions in donbass and
a real patriotism was seen in in this
support and historically this has always
been a feature of our nation
everyone everyone understands
uh the connection of their personal
uh life to the life of of their
motherland
dear friends I'd like to thank everyone
all people of Russia for
decisiveness and for their heroic
attitude I'd like to thank our offices
of Navy and Army and all the forces to
the fighters of donbass and Logan's
Christian to volunteers who are fighting
in
different areas and bars as well
uh I apologize that I will not be able
to name everyone When I Was preparing
this speech there was a long long list
of heroic units military units
I will not be able to name all of them I
did not want to offend anyone but not by
not naming them I would like to
bow down to
um relatives and wives
and parents and wives and and families
and doctors and instructors nurses who
are saving the wounded to the railroad
workers construction workers who are
creating the defense structures and also
building uh homes and Engineers of
Defense factories who are working
several shifts now to agricultural
workers who are supplying a constant
stream of
food and products
I would like to thank teachers who are
sincerely taking care of the new
generation of Russians especially those
who are working in very difficult
conditions near to the front line
all the
cultural figures who come to the front
light to who come to the hospitals to
support them to journalists
first of all military journalists
who are risking their lives in order to
tell the truth to the whole world
representatives of
of a traditional religions who are
supporting the military entrepreneurs
government officials everyone who is
fulfilling their
National and human Duty
I would like to express special
gratitude to citizens of Logan danielsk
republics and Zappa Roshe region view
yourselves determined your future you
made your choice despite the threats of
Terror of the Nazis
even though next to you there were
military action uh actions taking place
and you made the choice to be together
with Russia to be together with your
motherland
we have
started and we will continue to grow
I'd like to emphasize that this reaction
of our audience
addressed to the citizens of Donetsk and
logansk and zaparosian hairson regions
we bow down to you we
begin and we will continue our program
of social restoration and of these
territories and the idea is to bring
back the factories and the and the
industry and we will
create access to our internal C now as
of C we will create the new highway to
Crimea
and connected to the rest of Russia and
all regions of Russia are
providing direct support to cities and
towns of danielskin lugansk and other
regions and they're doing it as real
brothers and sisters together today
we're together again
and that means we're stronger again and
that means we're going to do everything
in order to bring our land back to peace
in order and to ensure security
it is for this for our ancestors for the
future of our children and grandchildren
in order to restore historic Justice
this is what our Fighters are fighting
for and our heroes are fighting for I
would like to
to
uh
to respect the memory of all people of
all fighters who died in military action
and all civilians who died in this
marriage reaction
thank you
we understand
that it is very hard for wives and
daughters and sons
of of our military personnel they have
brought up a very distant uh Defenders
just like our ancestors were defending
donbass
and they
they have got a very strong spirit and
our duty is to support those families
who lost loved ones
and help them
bring up their children
the family of every member of the
special military operation needs to be
surrounded with care and attention and
and we need to respond to their needs
very very quickly
I propose to create a special State Fund
whose objective would be personal help
to the families and Veterans of special
military
operation and those who died in action
this fund will coordinate
social medical and psychological support
they will provide
in helping educational sport in
entrepreneurship
in providing new professions and
professional development
and also long-term Home Care
for all those who are in need of it and
I'm requesting the government and the
committee on social affairs
together with regions
to resolve all organ organizational
aspects of this within the shortest
possible time
and also provide these services without
any bureaucracy
through a one window system every family
I emphasize every family of Fallen
uh Soldier
and every veteran of the action has to
have a personal contact
in in this fund
who will
in real time
deal with current issues I'd like to
point out that the structure of this
fund has to be deployed this year by the
end of this year
we already have measures of supporting
the veterans of the Great Patriotic War
and the veterans of other local
conflicts and
we need to work on this and improve this
I'd like to emphasize that creation of
this special fund does not alleviate
other structures of their responsibility
I'm expecting from all municipalities
all bodies to continue
provide to continue providing uh careful
um
help to all the veterans and we have
representatives of regions who
constantly are in contact with veterans
who constantly support families who who
go to the front line to support the
troops
um
we are talking about the supply about
payments and benefits in case of their
um in case they are wounded
and governors local Governors are
addressing me and Reporting me to me on
the result of their work and they and
they're saying that there are certain
issues that are not resolved yet and we
need to work on those
we all understand very well that the
needs of the special military operation
connected to a great burden
psychological physiological Financial
all participants of the special military
operation especially and including the
volunteers
they they need to have 14 days of arrest
um
every year without taking into account
the
um
in addition to the travel time
dear colleagues
we have an approved plan of
of creation of uh military force
for the
2023 2025 and we are working on it and
correcting it as we go and I'd like to
emphasize that further steps on
strengthening our Navy and army
we have to rely in these steps on our
real military experience this is
extremely important this is invaluable
for example the level of
of
the level of supply and Readiness of our
military nuclear military forces is in
the region of 91 percent taking into
account the experiences were received we
have to achieve that level of supply for
all other areas of Army and Navy
offices and Sergeants
who
demonstrates on themselves to be
decisive and clever
and brave they should be
forwarded to the military academies and
they should become a very powerful
Reserve training reserve and they have
to become people in demand both in the
military and in the Civil sector
we need to understand that we need to
Value their contribution to the defense
of our motherland
we will continue implementing the latest
Technologies
which will improve the quality of our
army
so these developments and these types of
equipment and weapons already there some
of them are exceeding the parameters of
Western
um
Western Equipment and our objective is
to create a mass production of
of these weapons using our own
industrial and scientific base
using State contracts and involving
small and medium Enterprise
we have scientific teams engineering
teams and we have more and more of
younger people qualified people in these
teams and we have very long traditions
of
weapon production and weapon
manufacturing and everything needs to be
done for the victory
we need to provide guarantees for
employees and we're talking about the
social benefits and also salaries and
I'm proposing to provide special
program for housing
and the rent in in this housing would be
significantly lower than the market rent
and the difference will be covered by
the state
that's for the employees of the defense
sector
we will work on the details of this
program and we will immediately start
building this housing especially in the
cities which are our military and
Engineering centers
dear colleagues as I mentioned the West
has begun not just the military but and
information but also
um
an economic
aggression but they have not achieved
success in either of these areas
and they won't achieve success there
moreover the initiators of the sanctions
are punishing themselves
they provoked a growth of prices in
their own countries closures of
factories
collapse of energy sector
they are telling their citizens that
it's it's the Russians who are to blame
and they've used
they've used different tools they tried
to
break commercial connections with our
companies
they try to impose they
they try to restrict our expert
and theft I I can't name it any other
way theft of our currency Reserves
and also attacks on our infrastructure
I'd like to emphasize that all sanctions
are just a means but the objective as
the West
says and I say directly to force our
citizens to suffer
this is their humanistic approach
they are trying to destabilize our
society from inside
but
their attempts
were not justified
and were not successful
thanks to joint work of our government
of the bank of Russia of the subjects of
the Russian Federation of the
um
of working people we were able to ensure
stability of economic situation we
preserved employment we supported our
financial system
business people who are investing in the
development of their business and
therefore in the development of the
country
we've launched a package of measures to
support the economy
totaling and the region of three
trillion rubles I'd like to point out
that these are not in me this is not a
money printing policy all of that is
based on Market
um principles
as at the end of 2022
the GDP is reduced
yesterday that information was published
and
remember they were saying that our
economy will drop 20 25 percent
um
and we I was saying 2.9 and then later
we're saying 2.2 GDP
GDP reduced by 2.2 percent
and I'd like to remind you that in
February March they were
forecasting total collapse
Russian business has restructed its
Logistics and has established
connections with predictable partners
and there are many of those in the world
majority of them in the world
and in in in terms of international
payments the volume of payments has
increased and
uh
and if we
so we will continue working with our
partners
um
in
with the objective to creating a stable
um a stable
um
currency environment and these uh other
currencies that the dominant today will
will continue losing its uh status
and
it's not just us we're reducing payments
in dollars they are doing that
themselves
so
um cannons against of instead of butter
they they say
we should not repeat the mistakes of the
past we should not try to distract to
destroy our own economy we've got
everything in order to
safely continue develop to develop our
country and we'll continue to act
foreign
domestic sectors of economy not not only
did not reduce but they also increased
they increased in their size and and we
see that
that the housing for example increased
uh in terms of housing market we built
around 100 million square meters of uh
of uh new housing and agriculture has
also seen a great success
the Russian agriculture sector
uh
harvested a record crop of 150 million
ton of wheat
and
we know that
we will increase the
the volume of expert to 60 million ton
and about 10 15 years ago this was just
a dream
and this was a plan that seemed to be
fantastic
if you remember quite recently
we've got the former Vice
prime minister
here he will confirm and we've got the
just the expert potentially 60 million a
few years ago it was just 60 million
total crop
we we did not allow for the labor market
to drop either
and
today in this current conditions in this
conditions of difficulties
our labor market is even more
comfortable than it used to be
remember that pre-pandemic we had
4.7 percent
um
4.7 percent unemployment now is what 3.7
3.7 this is a historic minimum
and I'd like to repeat that the economy
of Russia
has overcome these risks yes many risks
were impossible to to predict or
calculate and we had to react very very
quickly
both at the level of the government and
the level of the business decisions were
taken very very quickly
and
private initiative played a key role in
here
small and medium-sized business
we were able to avoid
over-regulating the sector what's also
important is that the economic drop was
only registered in the second quarter in
the third and fourth quarter we saw a
growth
in actual fact we when we are moving to
a new cycle of Economic Development and
according to our expert assessment we
are moving to a new quality of
development
our domestic Market our
Personnel potential our
people
all of that allows us to really uncover
a great potential of rational areas and
we see great growth of internal demand
domestic demand
and we have increased the production of
the of the products that are in most
demand and we were able to fill in the
niche that was
um was freed for us by Western companies
and we understand the number of problems
in logistics and economy in the finance
Staffing
we talked about
the need for structural changes in our
economy over the last few years and
today it's vitally important it's
necessary
and the situation has changed for the
better we know what needs to be done for
a sustained development of Russia
despite any external pressure and threat
guarantees of security and stability of
the country the whole
meaning of our work is not to adapt to
the current conditions our strategic
objective is to bring our economy to a
new height
everything is changing very quickly now
this is not just a time of challenges
it's also time of opportunities
and
and our future depends on how we use
these opportunities we need to remove
any
intergovernmental conflicts any
conflicts within this governmental
structure everything has to be aimed at
the objective at the result
and we need to stimulate small
family-run businesses and this is uh
this is a win creating new roads also
when creating and opening new schools
and kindergartens this is also when new
scientific breakthroughs also win and
all of that
contributions to our common success
what are the areas where we have to
focus on where we have to work together
between the government and the business
first of all we have to increase our
International connections and establish
our new logistical roots with new
partners and we have to create the
high-speed
Road between
um
and so forth we will continue developing
the ports of the Black Sea and as of sea
and we will especially pay attention
and we're already paying attention
to the corridor
South
north south
Volga caspi Canal will open to to the
boats with
uh 4.5 meter depth
and
we will modernize the Western uh the
Eastern direction of our railways
and
this will ensure not just additional
cargo flows but also will help us
develop Siberian Far East
we will be focusing on the
infrastructure of the regions including
Communications roads and in 2024 around
85 percent of the roads of the largest
conglomerates and also half of the roads
of the
national roads will be brought up to a
new level of quality
we will continue our road our
development of
gas supply to various
infrastructural
um to various infrastructure like for
example hospitals and schools and so on
and this would be done for free
so starting from this year we will begin
a big project for
modernization of our utilities and we
are investing about 4.3 billion rubles
in into this I don't know everyone knows
how important this is and everyone knows
that there are problems in this area
it's important that this program gets a
good start straight away and gets stable
financing the second is that we are
going to focus on development of of our
technological uh potential of our
economy
so we will launch products launch
industrial mortgages
so now people will be able to apply for
a loan for infrastructural projects and
building
um property for their companies
the
so the volume of financing on these
loans will be up to 500 million Rubles
and this would be three to four percent
interest
five to seven years I think this is a
very important program
starting from this year we will have a a
new mode of working for industrial
clusters
the demand for the Innovation products
that is
produced by these companies will be will
be supported by the government and
subsidized by the government
and
we are
we have a program up to 2030 to finance
these sort of products to the tune of 10
billion rubles
and I'd like to
reiterate that these are not just
forecasts these as specific figures
which we put in place and we will work
on launching those
we are supporting business and providing
systematic support
infrastructural support
tax support to the business
the taxed system has to be comprehensive
and it has to uh it has to be approached
with a very creative uh with a very uh
um
creative spirit
and starting from this year Russian
companies will be able to lower their
tax burden if they are purchasing
domestic I.T Solutions
and these costs will be will be
accounted at the rate of 1.5 so every
Ruble company invests in buying this
domestic products
their tax base will be reduced by 1.5
rubles
and this will cover
this will cover a high high technology
equipment produced in Russia
and we will
um
we will look we will look deeply into
this
this is a good solution which will
stimulate the economy a third is
an important
point on the agenda is the new sources
of financing and investment
thanks to our strong balance we do not
have to ask for money abroad
we don't have to conduct a long lengthy
dialogue about what and how much and
that what terms
our domestic banks are stable
and they've got uh
and in
2023 we saw that the financing of
corporate sector has grown has grown and
we had some doubts about this however we
saw a growth in 2023
and
this is uh growth compared to 2021 in
2021 growth was
11.7 percent and now 14 percent
the mortgage portfolio has also grown by
20.4 percent so we've got development
according to the results of last year
banking sector received a profit not as
significant as in the previous years but
very significant
so this is also an indicator of
financial stability of
banking sector
according
according to our figures inflation in
Russia will be next to the
uh near four percent
and I'd like to remind you that in some
Western countries it's 17 18 20 percent
and here we've got four maybe five
percent you know there's a dialogue with
the Central Bank they're giving their
own figures
taking into account the positive
Dynamics
we see that we've got objective
conditions
to lower long-term
loan rates and that means that the
financing has to become more available
what's very important is a long-term
Savings of Russian citizens and we have
to stimulate that flow of that money
into the investment sector and I'd like
to ask the government to look at
launching a special government program
from April this year to create
additional conditions for citizens to
invest within the country and to make
money within the country and also to
guarantee the
contributions to
to in investment companies there has to
be a similar scheme
to ensuring Financial deposits in Banks
we know that uh
um
I end up I propose a proposed double to
double this figure when we talk about
investing in private Pension funds
to the tune of 2.8 million rubles
also we need to stimulate investment in
other financial instruments
separate Solutions are needed in order
to attract Capital to
high-tech sector
and there will be a mechanism for them
to place to place the Securities on the
internal market
for other companies and separate buyers
what's very important for financial
sovereignty is freedom of
Entrepreneurship
the attempts to contain Russia in this
regard demonstrated that Russians were
able to adapt very quickly
and ish each initiative that is
supporting Russia has to have has to has
has to have support from the government
and in this regard it's important to
come back to reviewing some of the
criminal codes which relates to economic
crime
of course the state has to control
what's going on in this area you should
not allow
free free-for-all kind of attitude but
we should not also
um over regulate here
so I'm
um
we're hoping that the government uh
together with authorities will be very
consistent in their work and I'd like to
propose to create special measures which
will
liberate
economic actions in in this field
in this regard to Dear colleagues
a little philosophical aside
I'd like to mention specifically that we
remember what problems and imbalances
late Soviet economy
had to face and
we remember the chaos of the 90s
and the country
started to create a new Economy based on
Market relations
and an example
the example for us was Western countries
and there were a number of Consultants
as you know
but it's not enough to just copy their
models
we know that Europeans and Americans
were arguing between themselves
how Russia should develop and what
happened as a result of it
our economy became Western oriented
and
generally we became the source of
Commodities and we understand the
reasons for this
but the new forming Russian business was
aimed naturally and as other
as other businesses around the world
aimed at extracting quick profit
and what was happening as a result of it
it was just the sale of resources of oil
and gas and
Timber and so on and
money was not invested into long-term
projects
and in order to break this negative
tendency
we see this
we needed years and years to break this
and we needed massive State investment
we have achieved visible results here
however I would like to emphasize that
we need to
take into account the conditions in
which our large business was developing
Technologies were Western
cheaper money supply was in the West
and naturally Capital started to flow
there as well
and unfortunately instead of expanding
our production manufacturing instead of
creating employment here in in our
country
as capital was uh spent buying Elite
real estate yachts and then so on
of course later on they started also
investing here but then the first wave
was spent on consuming Western Goods
and where you have the riches
this is where you have your children
this is where you have your education
and the future and it was very difficult
for the state to prevent this because we
lived in the conditions of a free market
and the latest events have demonstrated
that
the West
was just a ghost in terms of being a
safe haven
and those who
saw Russia as just a source of income
and were planning to live abroad they
saw that they were just they just got
robbed in the West
um many of you remember
I just kind of
joked that
you will be running around Western
courts trying to save your wealth in the
west and this is exactly what actually
happened
I'd like to add a very important point
none of the simple citizens of the
country
was sorry about those who lost
massive bank accounts in the West
nobody was sorry about those who lost
palaces and Yachts
in the West
and in their conversations
um in in their own homes I'm sure they
remember the privatization of the 90s
where the wealth of the state was
directed to these hands and
also this uh
this ostentatious wealth
and so on
so the the West has got the objective to
finish with Russia as
as the
um
as as the as a powerful uh player in the
East and they were trying to finance the
terrorists and they were trying to
contain our growth expansion
and the large Russian business
was responsible for strategic
factories where thousands of people used
to work which were determining economic
situation in certain regions which means
that the management and the owners of
these businesses are dependent on
Western Powers who are hostile to our
situation
and this is not a tolerable situation
yes everyone has a choice
some people want to
live
until the end of their life in an
arrested palace with uh arrested
account
somewhere abroad
it's their right
and we're not
attempt to we don't attempt to attack
this but we need to understand that to
the West these people are second class
um
persons and all of these uh purchased
titles of
all the titles will not help here and
they need to understand that their
second class citizens there
second class persons
but there is another choice to be with
your motherland
to work
for the benefit of your compatriots
not just to open factories but also
change life around you in cities and
towns and these entrepreneurs these
business people are plentiful
and this is where the future of our
business is
everyone needs to understand that these
sources of wealth and the future should
be only here in Russia
and then we will definitely create
a very robust self-sufficient economy
which is not closed to the world and is
using all these competitive advantages
the money that is obtained here has to
be spent on development of this country
we have to develop our infrastructure
tourist infrastructure and I would like
for those who
faced this aggressive attitude of the
West to hear me
running around
begging is does not make any sense
it's futile
it's futile especially today when you
understand who you're dealing with
do not get stuck in the past do not try
to
argue in court and and try to return
things you are strong people you've been
in this
game for many years people who went
through very difficult times start new
projects
invest in Russia invest into factories
and into
employment in create new infrastructure
in
education sport culture and this is how
you'll get the Gratitude of people many
generations of people in in the future
and the state will support you
foreign
call to our business to work in the New
Direction dear colleagues Russia Is An
Open Country and it's uh a unique
civilization
there is no we're not pretending to uh
to be special but this is our
civilization
we
our ancestors
busted to us and we have to preserve it
and pass it on and we will continue
developing our relationships with our
friends and we will accept all the all
the good things
but first of all we will rely on our own
potential or in our traditions on our
values and here I would like to talk
about the character of our people we
were always generous compassionate and
Russia as a country reflects these
qualities we know how to be friends we
know how to keep a word
and not to fail anyone and we always
support people in difficult conditions
and we always support
those who are in trouble you remember
that during pandemics we were providing
support to other European countries
Italy and other countries in those who
had the most difficult times
and we do not forget how we help
in in this conditions of the earthquakes
in Syria and turkey
it's the people of Russia it's the basis
of sovereignty of
of our people and our
rights of our people
um
cannot be shaken and we're not going to
step away from this basic rights of our
people
and in this relation I would like to
emphasize that local
elections and in Autumn this year and
also president election in 2024 will be
conducted according to the law
um following constitutional procedures
we have various approaches to resolving
social issues
however all the powers all the forces in
society have to rely on some very basic
principles safety
security and national interests of our
people I would like to thank you for
this responsible position and I would
like to remind you of stellupian's words
who said this one more than 100 years
ago but this can be said today he said
that in the business of Defense of
Russia we all have to unite we have to
coordinate our forces and our rights in
order to support
one supreme historic right right of
Russia to be strong
thank you
among volunteers who are on the front
line there are members of State Duma and
Regional parliaments representatives of
various power levels representatives of
municipalities all parliamentary parties
all of them are participating in
creating this support for the front line
again I would like to express my
gratitude for such patriotic stance
very significant role in our civil
society is played by local government
these people are closest to
to the people and
they trust to our state depends on on
them and I'm asking the administration
of the president together with the
government
to create tools of direct support for
best management teams local government
teams
in municipalities and
local areas
those who are able to take
responsibility for themselves and for
for their people
and in order to strengthen our core
values
what's very important is the educational
system using the resource of the
President Grant and uh
other programs that we have available we
will continue
supporting our
education and art different areas of art
modern and
traditional classic
we will continue
thinking about very
difficult issues in life and most
important thing is not to destroy
Society but to stimulate the best
qualities in people
developing cultural sphere would be one
of the priorities for Don boss and
loganska new areas we will be creating
hundreds of cultural institutions
including museums
and centers
centers that will allow people to feel
the connection between the past and the
present and the future
that will allow them to feel the
belonging to the single cultural space
participation of teachers and
scientists Scholars we have we have to
use that participation node to create
the courses for literature and geography
so that the Young Generation is able to
learn as much as possible about the
our history we have a very talented New
Generation who is able to work for the
benefit of our country and it's for
these people that there's
New Horizons are opened by these
competitions that set
so this competition of leaders of
General regeneration
so the finalists of these competitions
some of them went to as volunteers to
work on the front light or work on the
development of
um
of these new regions restoring them
so the school of the military action is
something that cannot be replaced by
anything else
so these are the people who are prepared
to give their life for their motherland
I would like to emphasize that those who
were born and
grew up in Belarus and in donbass
they have and who fought for the
independence of these areas need to be
at the Forefront of our future
development and I would like to
emphasize that Russia is counting on you
taking into account this massive tasks
we have to renew our approach to
training
new personnel
and we talked at the Council of our
education we talked about priorities
that we have to focus on
obtaining very specific and concrete
scientific
results especially in the areas that are
critical to our future development is
including transport energy utilities
medicine agriculture industry
at the basis of new technologies there's
always fundamental Sciences Sciences
just like in culture
we have to provide scientists and
researchers greater freedom for
creativity
fundamental fundamental science lives
according to its own laws and we have to
give them freedom and we have to provide
stimulus to
young people to go into science
and we know that our best teams have got
something to be proud of
one of the issues
that we discussed was housing
and we already have housing certificates
for young scientists
and we are allocating 1 billion rubles
for these purposes
and I would like government to expand
this program
and we are also working on raising The
Prestige of uh
secondary professional education
we know that the number is uh numbers uh
have dropped significantly in this area
and we need that this we know that this
area needs to be developed
we are creating educational industrial
clusters
where
factories and
in industry is working very closely with
educational
[Music]
institutions and it's important that
um experienced employees who worked in
manufacturing Commerce teachers into
this educational facilities
so our electronic industry
robotics Pharmaceutical
agriculture construction defense
all these industries
all these industries are aimed at
ensuring security and the competitive
advantage of Russia
and finally a very important question a
very important question about our higher
School
higher education
we need to introduce some significant
changes take into account
change in demand in all areas of our
life we need to
ensure a synthesis of the best Russian
experience and experience of the last 10
years
here we're proposing the following first
we need to come back to the traditional
basic basic training of in the field of
higher education
with
the course length would be from four to
six years
and with this even Within
one
a Higher One University one University
can offer various programs depending on
the needs of the industry and needs of
of the market
secondly if there is a need for very
specialized training
then the person is able to continue
[Music]
studying to the level of ma and third
we will
um create a doctorate departments
and this transition to the new system
has to be
uh
should not be sharp it has to be a
steady transition
we need to work through all aspects we
need to look at all
elements and we
our Citizens need to have new
opportunities for professional growth
and professional education I would like
to reiterate opportunities not problems
I'd like to point out that the students
who are currently in education will be
able to continue their education
according to the existing programs and
the higher education diplomas
will be as acceptable as the new ones so
they should not lose their status so I'm
I'm asking this all Russian educational
fund to control these aspects of
of the new project
teaches
participating directly in the
construction of our future and it's
important to raise The Prestige of this
profession so that
parents
very respectful of the
teachers and the teachers are very
respectful of the parents
let's remember it
I would like to also talk about
support for families
the
children's budget so-called children's
budget
has grown not just by certain
percentages it's uh
it it's grown several times
and
I would like to thank our members of
parliament and government for this
Consolidated understanding of our
national priorities starting from the
1st of February
we have
increased the benefits Child Benefits
to 11.2 percent
now we have
the new subjects of the Russian
Federation have the same rights
we are providing mother's capital in
Logan's
Hearthstone regions to the families
where children were born starting from
2007.
what that means
what that means is from the moment
this program started working all over
Russia I'd like to
reiterate that we adopted the same
approach for Crimea and sevastopol and
we have programs which are aimed at
increasing welfare of uh of Russian
families
and the aim is to increase the real
income of Russian families
a very important Point here is the
minimum wage and it was
increased twice almost by 20 last year
and we will continue doing this
and this the
the pace at which this is done is
higher than the inflation
so since the beginning of this year it
was indexed by 6.8 percent
and I'm proposing
I am proposing to conduct to edit
another 10 percent to it by next January
so this means that
uh that means that the minimum wage will
be 19
245 rubles which is an increase of 18.5
percent
as for
tax systems for Russian families
starting from last year families with
two or more
children are freed from
from uh tax on sale of property
so we need to actively use these
instruments
so that family budget has got more
disposable income
and so that families can focus on
essential
challenges and also I would like to
propose
the deduction tax deduction
for
costs in relation to children's
education from 50 to 150 rubles and
medical costs
230 000 troubles
and this would be deducted this will
reduce their tax base
of the income tax base
we need to
also
um not just increase the amount to be
deducted but also
applicability
um you know the ease of use
the the ease of use of this um tool we
know that demographic situation directly
depends on the state of of the economy
for our families and we also need to
take care of aspects of culture and
support and housing and all of these
aerial areas will be supported
we
so the money for national projects that
were reserved in the federal budget for
will be available right now
and then there will also be
treasury loans interest treasury loans
that will be issued for these purposes
and this is a great tool
and we will
provide constant operational control
over these issues and I'm asking the
committee for for economy to look after
this matter
of course we do not need to hurry and
compromise the quality of construction
for this infrastructure project
this is very important for
for
healthcare system as well we've got this
massive program that we began in 2022
the main criteria
I mentioned this before the main
criteria is not the figures in your
reports the main criteria is visible
results in terms of accessibility of
Health Care
and quality of healthcare
also we are creating This
legal basis for purchasing of new
vehicles for
the healthcare
and these vehicles specialized Vehicles
will be able to provide Health Care in
remote areas
we're also working on the repair for
about 300 3500 schools using this
program so this year we will be doing
this in the nescan Logan regions
this is a very visible program people
see the results of this program in 2025
Federal money will be provided to
to
um the repairs of kindergarten schools
and professional colleges we should not
allow a situation where a building
becomes dilapidated
we had a program of building
1300 1300 schools from 2018 2024 we
already built 850 of those and so we
need to build another
400 and um
we need to ensure that we stick to this
program
and we've
we've spent about 490 billion rubles on
these programs since 2012 and we are not
decreasing this painting
this year we've increased the number of
infrastructure loans that are aimed at
additional I'd like to emphasize this
not not like before we've
allocated additional 250 billion rubles
on transport infrastructure in addition
to this we also provided 50 billion
rubles
which are aimed at
improving public transportation in the
subjects of the Russian Federation using
latest technology I would like to point
out that this this money will be aimed
at smaller cities and towns
we have taken the decision to extend
our project clean Waters
until 2030. and the objective of it is
to clean the water in
in industrial areas and significantly
reduce the harmful discharges
in the industrial areas
we are
expanding our
potential of treating the waste
so that we have a closed cycle uh
waste treatment systems
and I'm asking the government together
with the regions to prepare a list of
those facilities
and that will be where
Carnival discharges will be liquidated
at the end of this program
we will extend this work
to other of uh Rivers like uh Dawn
eritis Ural and other areas other
Rivers we should not forget our smaller
rivers and I'm pointing the attention of
all levels of government to this
we've also
prepared draft law for tourism in
protected areas this is something we
discussed with the government and
there's
law has to clarify
very clearly very clearly put out
describe what can be built and what
cannot be built in different areas which
are protected and I would like to speed
up the consideration of this law a few
words
about what's going on around us
dear colleagues
I'd like to
highlight another area at the beginning
of February this year there was a
statement of North Atlantic Union with
actual requirement to Russia
as they say to come back to the
Strategic
weapons including
inspections to our nuclear facilities
I don't know how to call it
this is an total appsword
we know that West the West is
is directly linked to the attempts of
cave regime to attack our strategic
Aviation basis
and the NATO specialist helped in
directing
and meant aircraft to attack these
these facilities and they want to
inspect our
facilities today this is just nonsense
it sounds like nonsense I'd like to
point out that
um
they're not allowing ourselves to
conduct a comprehensive
audit of facilities or inspection
facilities and they they are
declining our attempts to inspect those
facilities I'd like to emphasize that
U.S and NATO are directly stating that
their objective is to strategically
defeat Russia
and after that
are they thinking that they're going to
just uh tour our facilities
military facilities
and recently we've
I've
passed a lot to uh to to put the new
Strategic Defense
facilities and areas are they going to
visit those as well
with their Collective statement
NATO has actually
uh
attempted to become a member of this uh
of this agreement of strategic weapons
control
we agree to this
we feel that this is long overdue
nuclear Arsenal is not just
in America it's also in in the UK and in
France and they keep developing and
they're also aimed against us they're
also again aimed at Russia
their latest statements of their leaders
only confirms this
we cannot
we do not have the right not to take
this into account
The First Agreement on restricting
strategic weapons was signed in 1991
with the US
this was in a principally different
situation this was in the context of
mutual trust and following that our
relationships went
to such a level where U.S and Russia
stated and Soviet Union stated there
were no longer considering each other
enemies
the agreement of 2010 has got a very
significant uh points on indivisible
security and limitation of of strategic
weapons but this has been long forgotten
and U.S has exited that agreement
our relationships have
deteriorated and this
and this was
the initiative of the United States and
it was them who wanted to to review the
results of the second World War
and for this they started to destroy all
the basics of world order after the
Second World War
and step by step they started to destroy
the system of
world security and control of weapons
and they've conducted a number of Wars
around the world and all of that
was done with a single purpose to
destroy the structure of international
relations that was set up after the
second World War
and after the collapse of the Soviet
Union
they
they have been constantly trying to
reiterate their Global dominance
and this is not just in relation to
Russia but other countries as well
course the situation has changed since
1945 there are new centers
of influence and they keep developing
and this is a natural objective process
that cannot be ignored
what is unacceptable is that us started
to restructure this uh
this in
only according to their own needs
and now the NATO countries are offering
an ultimatum and they are saying that
Russia you have to comply
the and including this agreement on
control of strategic weapons
they are saying there is no connection
between
conflict in Ukraine and other hostile
actions of the West
um
their statements that they would like to
inflict a strategic defeat
on us this is a
this is the either they're very cynical
uh ultimately cynical or or
stupid
it looks like they're not stupid they
are aiming to inflict the Strategic
defeat
so there's uh
statement that Russia is uh is halting
putting a stop on its participation in
the Strategic weapons control agreement
I would like to reiterate
we're not exiting the agreement
we are
putting a halt on it
before we come back to the discussion of
this
we need to understand
what France and the UK are
trying to do and how we are going to
take into account their strategic
arsenals so their cumulative striking
potential
so their statement if effectively is the
application to enter this agreement okay
fine and you should not try to lie to
everyone
we know all the
the backstory to this we know that all
the
separate types of nuclear weapons are
coming to their expiry and
we know that they are thinking about
testing their nuclear weapons including
the fact that in the U.S they are
developing new types of nuclear weapons
and we have this information
and in this relation
Russia has to ensure
Russia has to ensure the Readiness of
the Russian nuclear potential of course
we're not going to strike first
and nobody has to have dangerous
illusions that this Global strategic
parity can be destroyed
dear colleagues the citizens of Russia
today we are going through a very
difficult
path and we are overcoming all
difficulties together
it could not be any other way because we
are brought
um
on
on our on the example of our ancestors
and this is passed from one generation
to another only dedication to our Unity
to our motherland
that Unity
has been demonstrated since the first
days of the special military operation
uh hundreds of volunteers
representatives of full ethnicities came
to the conscription centers in order to
fight for the truth for the justice for
interests of people in donbass and now
shoulder to shoulder we have
um
fighters from all types from all parts
of Russia and their prayers are in
different languages but all of them are
fighting for truthful and for the
motherland
and the heavy military duty their
the heroic Acts
finding a response in in Russia people
are supporting their military
and they cannot
be just standing aside
the front line is going through the
millions of Hearts of Russian Russian
citizens
people are doing everything they can in
order to preserve the lives of our
people
of our guys in the front line
um people going to the front line uh
taking this letters from the children
because uh because they know that these
are sincere words and they understand
why they're fighting who they're
protecting
this is uh
the care that is provided by volunteers
right from the start of the military
operation
is very important to them and the
volunteers are
helping civilians to go to cover and
provide water and
and clothing to civilians who are under
who live in the military
action areas and they continue saving
them and saving others
and we know that one of the funds
collected over 5 billion rubles for the
needs of the front and this work is
being conducted constantly uh companies
and entrepreneurs are helping but what
is especially touching especially
inspiring
is when people with small income uh
providing part of their salary or their
savings to help people on the front line
and
and this supports to our military this
supports to the refugees is very
important thank you for the support we
cannot overestimate the support
Russia
will will respond to any challenges
because we're all a single country we
are one big United people
we
we are confident in our power
truth is with us
thank you